Well, we don't need another reason to adore Ina Garten,
the Barefoot Contessa, my favorite, I love her.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
You know, whenever anyone asks me
like the celebrity that I've never met,
who I've always wanted to meet, I always say her,
I just love her, because she reminds me of my mom,
they have the same haircut and she cooks like my mom.
I just love you.
Well, "Insider" reports that Ina Garten,
turns out she's just like us,
she's got her own self-doubts, you guys.
In fact, she just revealed that she says
she's not a very confident cook.
I know, Ina Garten, the Barefoot Contessa, what?
Well, despite being one of the most famous chefs
on planet Earth and our favorite,
she says that cooking is really hard.
Even when she's making dinner for like four people,
she says to herself, "How is this gonna happen?"
Which I have to say makes me feel better
about all the kitchen disasters I've had in my life.
(audience laughing)
She says her insecurities come
from never having been formally trained
and I think that you and I can both relate,
'cause both of us love to get in the kitchen,
but I didn't go to culinary school.
You've done some classes, right?
Didn't you go to-
I've done some classes
and I'm an amateur, humble home cook,
but I don't relate to her in the kitchen,
I relate to her like at work in general.
How do you mean?
Well, I'm not a chef,
so I'm not gonna even pretend to relate to her there.
I just think like, oh wow, that's really refreshing to hear
that I think we all go through, you know,
just such inner voices,
that we have to kind of figure out how to master.
They're not doing us many favors a lot of the time
and it's sort of like, maybe it's like this thing,
that's there to test us to help us evolve
and grow strong and figure out how to find that confidence.
And you just look at someone like her
and she ironically seems so effortless.
Yeah.
So I'm like, oh, my gosh,
if she struggles too, like maybe we're not all so crazy
and it's a big part of the journey of life,
because sometimes I'm like, it is so crazy in here,
that to hear Ina Garten struggles sometimes,
I'm like, oh, okay, well, maybe we all do.
Yeah, yeah, someone who's as good at what she does,
as she is can have those self-doubts,
so maybe we should cut ourselves a little slack
every now and then, right?
Why did you say it so much better, so much quicker?
Because I heard you say it first.
(audience applauding)
Well, some people travel with their kids
and some bring their dogs and now you can bring your plants.
Apartment Therapy reports the Elwood Hotel
in suites in Lexington, Kentucky
is "The first plant-friendly hotel."
That's right, plant lovers can check in with their fern,
no questions asked and enjoy
the Gardener's Premier Corner Room,
a lush suite decked out with plenty of plants
plus a succulent souvenir to take home.
Apparently the greenery starts in the lobby,
where there's a giant fiddle leaf fig
and if you know what that is, then it might excite you.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
So I mean, I thought plants like to stay where they were,
I didn't know they liked to travel.
(audience laughing)
I got a real fussy plant at home.
Yeah.
Maybe I should take her there.
Take her on a road trip maybe.
(audience laughing)
You know, I'm just gonna leaf this one alone.
Oh!
Thank you, I can't.
(audience applauding)
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
Oh yes, you did.
I did.
Well, I'm all about it, I'd love to check out this hotel.
You think?
I would, there's a lot of weird gimmicks out in the world,
this one seems real harmless and sweet.
Yeah, I'm good, I'll be down at the Hilton.
(cheerful upbeat music)